i'm confused i don't know what's going
on i'm
lost i don't speak the language i'm
confused
people are yelling at me people are
getting mad at me i don't even know
what's going on brittany
went through it this episode hey my 90
day fans fam
it's melisia here per usual i'm going to
update you on all the highlights from
the latest episode of the other way
in just a few but first let's do a deep
dive
into the biggest moment which goes to
britney's crazy fight
with yazan's mom now there's a lot to
break down here
so we're gonna kick it off with how the
argument
started as expected when britney arrived
with yazan at his parents house his dad
began to question them
about when they planned to get married
actually
he didn't question them he basically
told them that hey
you two need to get married within the
next few days
definitely
oh like what's
like first talking with your dad and
sunday we want to
sign paper marriage on sunday
yes britney on sunday now if you don't
remember
britney is still married so her game
plan going into this
was to tell yazzan's parents that she
doesn't want to get married right now
because she wants her family at the
wedding
i'm actually really stressed out with
yazon's parents trying to pressure me to
get married right away
it's gonna take like a little time for
my family to get the plans together
and plane tickets yazan's dad might not
be that fluent in english
but you can tell that whatever britney
is saying
he's not buying it things really started
to escalate when yazan's dad
asks brittany if she's been taking the
time to study
islam and she flat out said no
that's when things took a turn for the
worse
and then you're like slowly i can't be
like this i wish there was something
saying that
i'm not a baby you might be no i'm not
good
at this point yazan's mom just went
off
i'm not from here i don't understand
what's going on
i told you britney went through it
this episode after she walked off
yazan's dad told yazan to go after her
and as you can see she was visibly
shaken
from the conversation i spoke to
brittany last month and i asked her
on a scale of a one to ten how does she
rate her relationship
with yazan's parents right now um
i wanna say that i do love
yazon's parents i i don't know
exactly where his parents stand
i can't speak for them and i won't speak
for them but i will speak
to say that i love them and i do think
that they try their best
to um deal with the situations at hand
with their experiences and their
lifestyle so i think they're just doing
the best that they can i don't blame
them
and that's their son 100 so that's their
baby and i understand all of that
hey i just hope this relationship is
worth it
for yazan and brittany because this is a
lot
a lot a lot next up we have another
90-day parent who
didn't hesitate to speak their mind so
how are you today
that's good doesn't it i'm a mess
right now i'm not a snob i just come
from a totally different culture
i've been in places that are poor the
people are nice
but the fact is that the conditions here
not safe for a baby
i think you need to see really what she
gave up to come here
after that conversation beniam took
ariella
and her mom to go look at a new
apartment
and unfortunately it's worse than the
first one
this is a kitchen this is a kitchen we
can buy
for stove here like this apartment is a
mess
the first one was bad enough and the
second one is just a disaster
so there it's going to be a refrigerator
freezer over here yeah
but how do we how do you plug it in
would remove the cables this is the
powers
no but if it's over here the cords are
going to go across the room
it would be months before they could get
it together for someone to live in and
harry doesn't really have that time she
needs something good right now
what did ariella get herself into this
is so much
right so much something we have to look
forward to
next week is kenneth meeting up with
armando for the first time
since he made it to mexico i've waited
for this moment for
a very long time i can't wait to see his
face
hello oh i can't wait to see that
all right my 90 day fans fam make sure
you stick with e.t because here
we are covering it all see you next time